Bran Stark: The Starks of Winterfell trace
their descent to the First Men in the Age
of Heroes.
The family's founder was Brandon the Builder
who, in the aftermath of the Long Night, helped
establish the Night's Watch.
Legend has it, he enlisted the aid of giants
and the powerful magic of the Children of
the Forest to raise the mighty Wall, which
has protected the realm for generations.
He went on to build the ancestral seat of
Winterfell and reigned as the first King in
the North.
The Starks take great pride in their history
and traditions.
It is one of the few noble houses that still
keeps the Old Gods; a sacred weirwood lives
large in Winterfell's godswood.
Its ancestral sword, Ice, was forged in ancient
Valyria and passed down through the generations.
House Stark remains steadfast in its support
of the Night's Watch, even as the once illustrious
order has fallen on hard times.
Much like their sigil, the grey direwolf,
House Stark is the stuff of legend in the
North and throughout the Seven Kingdoms...
Bran and Robb Stark: ... and their family
words, "Winter Is Coming" serve as a reminder
of their beginnings...
Robb Stark: ... in the wake of the Long Night
and a grim portent of things to come.
Roose Bolton: Like the Starks, the blood of
House Bolton runs back to the First Men.
Singers call those times the "Age of Heroes."
A mask for a savage world that bred savage
men.
The Lannisters swindled their enemies, the
Storm Kings hammered them, and the Starks
cut off their heads.
In such company as this, were the Boltons
really so indelicate?
Unlike some other houses, my ancestors earned
the Bolton words, "Our blades are sharp."
They passed down not a Valyriangreatsword
but a knife honed and thin enough to fit between
the topmost layer of skin and the tissue below
and peel.
For as we all learned as children, a naked
man has few secrets; a flayed man, none.
In those dark days, they say some of my more
wilfulforebearers would even wear their enemies'
skins as cloaks.
But no such tokens remain if they ever existed.
Certainly not hanging in some secret room
in the Dreadfort, as old wives and fools insist.
I suspect my House itself was responsible
for spreading such rumors in the first place.
Few weapons are as effective as terror, and
this was an age of war.
House against House, brother against brother.
The ironmen were on the rise and never far
from our shores.
We must have seemed ripe for the taking, too
busy fighting each other to deal with the
raiders as they deserved.
Thus the Starks took it upon themselves to
unify the North under them.
They drove the pirates out of White Knife
and claimed the eastern coast and married
the Marsh King's daughter for the Neck.
A Stark wrestled for Bear Island and won,
or so they say.
Silly stories.
Blood and steel won the North, and the Starks
had the most of both.
Sansa Stark: With most of the South in Aegon's
hands, the best chance to throw back the Conqueror
now lay with the North, if we cared enough
to try.
Unlike our southern rivals, the Stark Kings
of Winter didn't forge the North into one
kingdom for glory or gold (there is little
of either here), but to survive.
Alone in Westeros, the North remembered when
worse than dragons lay waste to armies.
Thousands of years ago, the sun set on the
realms of men, and the Long Night began.
A new race emerged from the ice and snow:
the White Walkers.
They demanded no crown, offered no terms,
spared no life, and the dead marched with
them.
With humanity facing extinction, a Stark sought
out the Children of the Forest, the most ancient
beings in Westeros, and convinced them to
ally with the men they'd once fought.
Together, the two races pushed the Walkers
back into the Land of Always Winter and sealed
it off from the Seven Kingdoms with the Wall,
three hundred miles of ice, stone, and earth
rising nearly seven hundred feet tall.
To guard it, they established the Night's
Watch, a brotherhood sworn to defend the living
from the dead, whose vows erase both titles
and crimes.
Viserys Targaryen: After the Long Night, the
North tried to forget it belonged to a continent.
Perhaps through pride, perhaps through sheer
ignorance.
You never can tell with the North.
But as news of Aegon's dragons spread, Torrhen
Stark, the King of Winter, knew he couldn't
forget Westeros any longer and summoned his
lords to Winterfell.
Many fools shrugged off the threat while the
rest placed wages on how long the South would
take to burn.
Torrhen silenced them with a command to assemble
their armies and descend from the North in
force.
Sansa: As the kings of the Rock and the Reach
burned on the Field of Fire, the greatest
Northern force since the Long Night crossed
the Neck into the Riverlands.
But when King Torrhen arrived at the Trident,
he saw on the opposing riverbank the combined
strength of all Aegon's conquered kingdoms.
A force larger than Torrhen's own by half,
and with three dragons.
Viserys: That night, King Torrhen called a
conference of all his lords and advisors.
Some wanted to fight and trust Northern valor
to carry the day (and burn on the Trident).
The wisest of them wanted to withdraw to Moat
Cailin, the fortress which had thrown back
every southern invasion (and burn there).
One suicidal lord even wanted to ambush Aegon's
camp in the dark and kill the dragons as they
slept or at the very least, their riders.
Hard to tell what would have been his fate.
Burning?
Beheading?
Dismemberment?Perhaps all three.
Sansa: My ancestor listened to their counsel,
and, in the morning, crossed the Trident under
a flag of parley.
Then King Torrhen of House Stark laid his
ancient crown at Aegon's feet and was named
Lord of Winterfell and Warden of the North.
Viserys: And the King Who Knelt.
Sansa: He had no choice, and thanks to him,
our soldiers returned to their homes whole
and unharmed.
The swords that Aegon took from them were
not twisted, burnt, or mangled.
Viserys: Yet.
Barristan Selmy:Then came Lord Whent's tourney
at Harrenhal, the largest ever in Westeros.
I unhorsed every man against me until only
Prince Rhaegar remained.
We each set our feet in our saddles and lowered
our lances and charged, and I fell.
Muddy and bruised, I then watched Rhaegar
present Lyanna Stark with the victor's crown
of roses, though she was betrothed to Robert
Baratheon and Rhaegar himself was married
to Elia Martell.
We all know what happened after.
If I had I been a bit quicker with my lance,
had I chosen a faster horse, perhaps I could
have spared the kingdom from the destruction
that came after.
Or if I had thought to warn Brandon Stark
against his rashness.
He came to King's Landing himself demanding
Rhaegar return his sister.
Poor fool.
If he had only known the depth of Aerys' madness,
he wouldn't have dared provoke him.
Aerys ordered Brandon imprisoned, while I
could do nothing but obey.
When Brandon's father, Lord Rickard Stark,
came to King's Landing to beg for his son,
Aerys burned him alive, while I could do nothing
but watch.
I had sworn a vow to a mad king and was honor-bound
to obey him, even at the cost of my soul.
Varys: We urged Aerys to pardon Brandon Stark.
The boy had threatened Prince Rhaegar, but
Rhaegar had stolen the boy's sister, and the
boy was the eldest son of our Warden of the
North.
Baelish: Who is the greater fool: a mad king
or the man who reasons with him?
Aerys saw knives in every shadow.
When you told him to treat the Starks with
caution, you made him afraid and what he feared
he killed.
Varys: I wouldn't have thought you of all
people would bother with recriminations for
Brandon's death, Lord Baelish.
Not after your, shall we call it, "duel" with
him?
Baelish: Brandon was as arrogant as he was
stupid; like his father, Lord Stark, who answered
Aerys' summon to the capital.
They earned their fates.
But the younger son, Ned, what was his crime?
That Aerys ordered his death as well?
Varys: Unlike men, families do not die when
you lop off their head.
Baelish: When did you know you'd lost, Lord
Varys?
Varys: When Robert Baratheon killed Prince
Rhaegar on the Trident.
Baelish: Wrong.
You lost the war when you let Ned Stark slip
back into the North.
Neither the Bloody Gate of the Vale or Moat
Cailin in the North have ever fallen.
They could have held out for years even if
you'd killed Robert, but you let him slip
through your fingers as well.
Varys: I told the court that Robert was hiding
in the Stoney Sept, but the Hand of the King
wasted too much time searching the city.
Something about the glory of single combat.
Then Ned Stark's army arrived to save the
day.
Catelyn Stark:Robert won and my husband avenged
his brother and my love.
But when he came home to me, he could not
meet my eyes.
I saw the reason by his side.
Many men have bastards, I know, and under
the strain of war, any man, no matter how
honorable, may forsake his vows for a night
of warmth that he may never know again.
But Ned Stark was not built like other men.
His northern honor would not let him sequester
his shame in some distant holdfast.
He brought this boy, this "Jon Snow," home
to raise with his trueborn children.
My children.
The Starks are of the North, and, like the
snows of winter, when they come south, they
melt away.